I know TJ I worked with TJ at um at CNN
so I have nothing but love for him and I
hope that he's okay Don Lemon offers his
robot well I'll say this I don't know
about their situation I'm not privy
enough but I just like to offer people
love and support and I hope that they're
okay and I hope I get to see them in
person again soon so I can give them a
hug well Don sending his support to an
old friend he's also rallying behind
this couple Prince Harry and Meghan
Markle who are receiving the Robert F
Kennedy award at the Ripple of Hope Gala
listen I'm in an interracial
relationship and I know how tough it is
and I know the scrutiny you get and I
can't imagine dealing with it on that
level and I actually think that they're
doing a good job with it look whatever
you think of them and whatever you think
of how they're handling it I think it's
a tough tough position to be in so I
like to offer people Grace instead of
criticism and more curious about why
they are who they are what they do what
they do why they're suffering with their
suffering and why they're handling it
the way they are I'd rather be curious
about that rather than being judgmental
you know when it comes to the pairs
upcoming Netflix series Don tells us
it's definitely on his watch list I plan
to watch it I'll watch it on my own time
I will probably have to watch it for
what I do but I'm not going to stay up
after midnight I'd wake up early I'm on
at 6 a.m in the morning so I do a
Morning Show I'll wake up at
4 15 and watch it maybe five o'clock and
then and then head to the studio quickly
[Music]